some people can't see the forest for the
trees but before Stephen silat no one
could see or even imagine the forest in
the trees Stephen was an explorer of New
Worlds from the start he spent his
boyhood in Harrisburg Pennsylvania
reading Tolkien and playing Dungeons and
Dragons with his brother Scott but when
the silat family visited their
grandparents cabin near Gettysburg their
grandmother Helen Poe silat would take
the boys into the nearby mountains and
forests to birdwatch they called grandma
silat Poe and she taught the boys to
identify songbirds plants and even
lichens creatures that often look like
splotches of carpet glued to the shady
sides of rocks and tree trunks looking
upwards both boys found their callings
Scott became a research scientist
specializing in migratory birds Steven
was more interested in the trees the
tangle of branches and leaves attracted
his curiosity what could be hidden up
there by the time Steven was in college
that curiosity pulled him skyward to the
tallest trees on earth the ancient Coast
redwoods of Northern California rising
from trunks up to 20 feet in diameter
redwoods can grow up to 380 feet or 38
stories over a 2,000 year lifetime but
no one had thought to investigate the
Crown's of these natural skyscrapers
were there more than just branches up
there Steven decided to find out
firsthand in 1987 Steven his brother
Scott and his friend Marv wood drove
from Reed College in Oregon to Prairie
Creek Redwoods State Park in Northern
California
deep inside the park Stephen picked the
tallest redwood he could find its lowest
branches were almost 100 feet up far
beyond his reach but he saw a younger
shorter redwood growing next to the
target tree with the running start he
lept and grabbed the lowest branch
pulled himself up and scurried upwards
he was free climbing without ropes or a
harness one misstep meant death
but up he went and when he reached the
peak he swayed and left across the gap
of space onto a branch of the target
tree and into a world never seen before
his buddy Marwat followed him up and the
two young men free climbed high into the
redwoods crowd Stephen came across
lichens like grandma poet shown him as a
boy he noticed that the higher he went
the thicker the branches were not the
case with most trees he found moist mats
of soil many inches thick made from
fallen needles bark other plant debris
and dust from the sky piled on the tops
of the large branches he even found
reiterations new redwood tree trunks
growing out from the main trunk the
redwood had cloned itself when Steven
reached the pinnacle he rested on a
platform of criss-crossing branches and
needles growing in the soil Matt was a
huckleberry bush with ripe berries he
ate some and waited for his friend
Stephen had discovered a new world
hundreds of feet above the ground his
climb led to more excursions with safety
equipment thank goodness up other
ancient redwoods as he mapped and
measured the architecture of branches
and additional trunks in the canopy of
an entire grove Stephen became an expert
in the ecology of the tallest trees on
earth and the rich diversity of life in
their crowns aerial ecosystems no one
had imagined
there are ferns fungi and epiphytic
trees normally found at ground level
like Douglas firs hemlocks and tan Oaks
whose roots had taken hold in the rich
wet soil mats invertebrates such as ants
bumblebees mites beetles earthworms and
aquatic crustacean copepods make their
homes alongside flowering plants like
rhododendrons current and elderberry
bushes Ospreys spotted owls and jays
search the canopy for food even the
marbled murrelet a Pacific sea bird
flies many miles from the ocean to nest
there squirrels and voles peek out of
penthouse burrows and the top predator
the mighty wandering salamander Siletz
research has changed how we think about
tall trees and bolstered the case for
their conservation not just as
impressive individual organisms but as
homes to countless other species so when
you look up into the branches and leaves
of a tree ask what else is up there a
new world might be just out of reach so
leap for it
you